bunny le gouvernement devrait prendre
rapidement de nouvelles mesures pour
lutter contre l'immigration clandestine
c'est ce que vient d'annoncer alain
juppé alors que le statu quo se prolonge
au tour d'un gymnase dans le 11e
arrondissement de paris 200 africains en
situation irrégulière ils sont
retranchés après leur expulsion hier de
l'église saint-ambroise anne consigny
pas d'accès autorisé cet après midi pour
les journalistes dans le gymnase japy du
11e arrondissement à l'intérieur 200
immigrés africains clandestins
continuent leur bras de fer pour obtenir
la régularisation de leur situation
depuis leur installation ici hier ils
redoutent une nouvelle expulsion on a
demandé
que la préfecture prevent des
associations de soutien et les délégués
des familles en cas d'expulsion de
manière à ce qu'on puisse sortir de ce
lieu la tête haute quelques membres de
plusieurs associations et médecins du
monde assure le ravitaillement
pour dormir c'est beaucoup plus
difficile
et baettig et on ne va pas laisser voir
les photos des sorties donc on a trouvé
détendu
les sols pour voilà l'occupation du
gymnase fait suite à celle de l'église
saint-ambroise entamé en début de
semaine les associations voulaient ainsi
attirer l'attention sur la situation de
ces clandestins qui vivent parfois
depuis des années en france mais à la
demande des autorités religieuses
l'église a été accueilli hier matin très
tôt quarante personnes ont été arrêtées
au cours de l'opération elles devraient
être expulsés à partir de lundi
elle pense mais vous le disais au cours
de leur expulsion de l'église
saint-ambroise 43 donc de ces africains
ont été placés en garde à vue pour
infraction à la législation sur le
séjour des étrangers en france